ladies and gentlemen let me introduce
our first speaker who is passionate
about innovation deputy mayor of
Marseille in charge of innovation
development for digital technology and
better communal living he is also a
member of the regional
provence-alpes-cote d'azur council in
south of digital technologies a pioneer
of the xmas a french tech he is working
on the development of a smart cheeky
strategy focused on proximity to
citizens and their concerns he's also an
active member of the smart region let me
welcome mr. Daniel spanning
okay my english isn't very good but I
try to tell you a few words in the
language of Shakespeare hello elected
representative ladies and gentlemen
ladies and gentlemen all players of the
connected world it's such a pleasure to
welcome you all in matzah in the name
and on behalf on our mayor mr.
jean-claude gaudin but I represent a
deputy mayor of our centers of
innovation digital technology and better
communal living the HT th concealed 2017
and there the high patronage of the
president of the French Republic and the
high patronage of our senator Meyer is
great digital international moment hbu
casion is given to share both our
knowledge and experiences a great
strategic opportunity for the world of
fiber and it's takes uncommented better
week ality of the speakers and that we
discussed subjects as well as the
synergy between reactors will confirm
the success of this k event that's why i
like to thank particularly FTTH conceal
organization board mr. Ronan Kelly
president of the ftth concede Europe I
wish but we applaud you for choosing
Massa please applaud
we tell the world director friend
digital agency all stakeholders involved
and all of you that have come in large
numbers from all over the world as a
real Mediterranean hub must a beautiful
city is a crossroad where everything is
possible under the edges of jean-claude
gaudin also the president of the
metropolis our ambition is to build an
attractive sustainable and livable
metropolis to face the challenge the
ultracaan activities a malefactor here
in the province we have chosen a cell
phone smart city policy at the ends of
better life together an innovation here
in the province of khadija region our
smart region is a watershed to
excellence which pragmatism its
president Christian s cozy counting
clearly unpromising fields and new uses
our open innovation is both an economic
growth sliver and services accelerator
being also a member of the regional
council in charge of innovation and
delighted that before catalysis our
competitiveness and our international
influence the high connectivity that
convinced yogen transformation and the
sharing of knowledge is useful for
social cohesion to fight against
fractures paradigms are changing
behaviors are evolving and economic
models are renewed to face with the
changes mehsana region have undeniable
numerous assets first of all the motor
boozer monopolization of the french
state is great it's france k 0 DB and at
connecting 35 million buildings by 2022
today fifty percent of the French
population is connected with very high
speed in Marseille it's up to more than
hey keepo sense as you know good
coordination between the players is
crucial but the reason why we have
created peccati as ve a privilege
original structure dedicated to very
high speed territorial policy verse
original master plans Skaugen for the
region's done for the Department and
others converge with real synergies the
pooling of resources and the
rationalizing of deployments of demise
our investments marseille makes its
contribution with an operator charter a
women partnership for protect rules
which brings us together on this point i
will add I would especially like to
thank our operatives private partners as
a fair numerical around three and week
with the high-speed connectivity we have
been able to develop our own NFC Near
Field Communication package of services
open to all fields such as transport to
his business citizen services sports
future education and health the new uses
have boasting important events such as
Marseille being european capital of
culture in 2013 be here marseille is the
european capital of sports besides world
big events a large number of maya
Congress related to digital business and
technology takes place in our city
marseille is definitely becoming the
mythic point of the international
digital business our second connectivity
strang in marseille our strategic
position situated on the convent point
of several international telecom
networks we have the most powerful
internet network in Europe almost 20,000
kilometers of covers 19 out 263 in the
world commenting connections and
data with success Marseille expresses
its leadership as a digital flagship of
the Mediterranean in line with this the
city of Marseille and region performs
projects of big data and open data
combining urban monitoring and IOT by
the way I would like to come too late
the Maya data centers such as Jaguar
network and interaction the whole group
of data centers strength then our third
asset our xmas a French tech flagship of
our digital industry the dynamic value
and employment creation ecosystem is
connected with the kallah T of our
business man and also with a high level
of our engineers who make french
reputation being close to the xmas a
university amid the biggest Franklin
University of the world in the world
which it's 100,000 students teachers and
searchers increasing the private-public
partnership with the industrial Field
lot of fun either projects as the camp
the European smart city countries
completely synergy to be concrete xmas a
french x represents 7000 films with
40,000 jobs and a billion euro to never
a growing economy waiting as much as the
port industry the top games of our
startups were recently awarded it at the
last 2017 s consumer electronics show in
las vegas these these routine films are
from now on proper led to a bright
future I like to conquer it congratulate
sorry three local startups for well
serious Innovation Awards so label 3d
runner and envelope in short it's no
coincidence if masa is said to be by the
OECD one of the most innovative cities
in the world for t3h most innovative
city on 445 the digital reprobate and
mas a mile smart data but born our
reality
for Marseilles people's to be connected
is as important as water electricity or
gas delivery the ftth is a great causes
bringing the world citizen the
connection knowledge and for the
territory staten able attractivity the
citizen as sometimes no idea of the huge
and invisible invisible work undertaken
in order to better succeed together no
matter how much we still have to
undertake our chance is to progress all
together within these FTTH conference
well gather around connectivity
crossroads they are used to be signed
scientists researchers and OA days now
they are connector expect that you
represent nearly 3,000 participants 155
speakers from 96 countries that you all
for you present let's hear for you
please
mouse a is glad to welcome you so sad
that add together we work and make
digital develop and become true towards
the citizens films local public
administration wherever they are in the
world becoming a smart city starts with
motley and very human future and new
experiences to conclude as it expresses
well the philosopher for man to build
his house is born a second time for the
citizens to co built its city is to born
the third time thank you for your
attention and enjoy you say in Marseille
[Applause]